Picture the scene: it’s January 24, 41 AD
and Rome is in chaos.
The tyrant emperor Caligula has just been
stabbed to death outside the Palatine Games.
In the city, his wife has been murdered and
his baby daughter had her head dashed open
against a wall.
In this tense, bloody atmosphere, no-one knows
what will happen next.
Will the Republic be restored, or will a new
emperor be found to take the throne?
At the height of this uncertainty, a soldier
in the Praetorian Guard sweeps aside a palace
curtain and finds Caligula’s useless uncle
cowering in fright.
But the Guard don’t kill the old man.
Instead they proclaim uncle Claudius Emperor.
Born into the imperial household in the days
of Augustus, Claudius was a sick, feeble child
never destined to amount to much.
Yet through a quirk of fate he became the
only candidate able to take the throne following
Caligula’s murder.
Hounded by assassination attempts, surrounded
by people conspiring against him, Claudius
nonetheless became one of the greatest rulers
in Roman history.
Join us today as we plunge into the unlikely
story of Rome’s accidental emperor.
The Family of Blood
On August 1, 10 BC, the Roman town of Lugdunum
(now Lyon, France) prepared to welcome the
latest member of the imperial household into
the world.
From the moment of his birth, Claudius - or,
to give him his full name, Tiberius Claudius
Nero Germanicus - was one of the best connected
people in the whole of Rome.
His father was the popular general Nero Claudius
Drusus, while his mother was Antonia the Younger.
If that doesn’t sound so impressive, wait
until you hear the next part.
His grandmother on his father’s side was
the wife of the current emperor Augustus.
On his mother’s side, he was descended from
Mark Anthony.
Not only that, but his uncle was the future
emperor Tiberius.
His older brother was Germanicus, the future
father of Caligula.
Claudius wasn’t just born with a silver
spoon in his mouth.
He was born practically suckling a whole cutlery
set.
Unfortunately, he was also born with a mysterious
disability.
We say “unfortunately” because ancient
Rome was not somewhere that viewed the disabled
kindly.
The Roman ideal was to be a strong male who
excelled at both athletic feats and oratory.
Being able to do only one of those things
was acceptable.
But neither?
Boy, would you be in for a bad time.
And a bad time is exactly what young Claudius
had.
He limped.
He stammered.
His head twitched oddly.
He was known to dribble.
For a family that prided itself on being the
most perfectly Roman of all Romans, this was
beyond embarrassing.
Claudius’s mother called him “a monster
of a man, not finished but merely begun by
Dame Nature.”
His grandmother refused to speak with him.
It’s said that when poor Claudius came to
dinner, the rest of the family would throw
food at him and jeer, mocking him for his
disability.
If that sounds horrific, just know that Claudius
was one of the lucky ones.
In those days, it was not uncommon for Romans
to simply kill disabled children.
The only reason the imperial family didn’t
do so is because that would’ve been an even
bigger embarrassment.
But while Claudius was disabled, he was by
no means the idiot his parents thought he
was.
The boy was insightful, intelligent.
A born academic.
At first, no-one really noticed.
After Claudius’s father died in 9 BC he
was dumped with a tutor who tried to beat
his disability out of him.
But, eventually, Augustus noticed Claudius’s
love of reading and, in 7 AD, decided to hire
the historian Livy as his new tutor.
This was an excellent move.
Livy didn’t try to beat Claudius until his
disability went away.
He gave him stacks of books to read, encouraged
him to write, even helped him prepare and
deliver speeches.
As young Claudius started to come out of his
shell, he began to earn begrudging respect
from his relatives - no mean feat when you
remember those relatives were all assholes.
Yet, even now, the imperial family kept Claudius
from holding any public office.
In private, they all agreed he should never,
ever be allowed to become emperor.
You can almost imagine the Fates looking down
on these pompous mortals and struggling not
to laugh.
From Bad…
The tortured chain of events that would eventually
lead to Claudius becoming emperor began on
19 August, 14 AD.
That day, Augustus passed away after four
decades on the throne.
In the wake of the First Citizen’s death,
Claudius’s uncle Tiberius became emperor.
Now, Tiberius was a weird choice.
He was about as popular as a rectally inserted
cactus, and had only been adopted by Augustus
because he had no other heirs.
Perhaps realizing that Emperor Butt-Cactus
would be a disaster, Augustus had tried to
mitigate things by making Tiberius in turn
adopt Claudius’s dashing older brother Germanicus.
That way, no matter how painful Tiberius was
for Rome’s metaphorical backside, the soothing
hemorrhoid cream of Germanicus would never
be far behind.
Unfortunately, Tiberius was a guy who believed
in all pain, no gain.
In 19 AD, Tiberius had Germanicus assassinated.
In the aftermath, he had all of Germanicus’s
relatives either killed or imprisoned.
Well, we say “all”.
But there were two conspicuous relatives this
sentient, spiky suppository forgot about.
The first was Claudius, who Tiberius considered
too weak and useless to even bother killing.
The second was Germanicus’s son: a pre-teen
boy who went by the nickname Caligula.
And that was basically how the rest of Tiberius’s
reign went.
Throughout the 20s AD, the emperor conducted
purge after purge.
Each time, he spared both useless Claudius
and helpless Caligula.
That’s not to say Tiberius liked his stammering
nephew.
He kept Claudius alive because he didn’t
see him as a threat, but also made sure to
keep him miserable.
When the senate tried to let the poor guy
join, Tiberius personally vetoed it for the
good of the empire.
On the other hand, the emperor also made a
choice that was very much not for the good
of the empire.
In 32 AD, Tiberius was reaching the end of
his life and needed an heir.
His son Drusus had died the decade before,
and he needed someone to fill the boy’s
little boots.
He chose Caligula.
Technically, he made Caligula his co-heir
alongside Caligula’s cousin, but you don’t
need to bother learning heir number 2’s
name, because Caligula quickly made sure their
was no second heir to worry about.
That done, he smothered Tiberius with a pillow
in 37 AD - at least, according to tradition
- and had himself declared sole emperor.
Since you’ve doubtless already seen our
Caligula video - and, if not, do we have a
glorious Roman clickhole lined up for you
- you already know that Caligula’s reign
was extremely not-fun for everyone in Rome.
But not for Claudius.
Almost as soon as Caligula took the throne,
he had his uncle elevated to consul, the first
position of power the now-47 year old had
held.
To this day, nobody really knows why Caligula
showed Claudius such favor.
Theories range from “he wanted to keep his
potential enemies close” to “dude, he’s
Caligula, he’s completely cuckoo.”
Yet even now a dark cloud was forming that
threatened to block Claudius’s unexpected
ray of sunshine.
In December that year, Caligula’s sister
Agrippina the Younger gave birth to a son.
She called him Lucius Domitius Ahenobarbus.
But you know him by a different name: Nero.
… to Worse
While Caligula had taken a shine to Claudius,
that didn’t mean the older man was safe
from his nephew’s whims.
By all accounts, Caligula treated Claudius
more like a court jester than a relative,
pushing him in the river for fun and forcing
the poor guy to rack up huge debts funding
Caligula’s lifestyle.
Still, considering what happened to most people
in Caligula’s orbit, Claudius got off relatively
lightly.
This was the emperor who forced parents to
watch their children being tortured to death.
The emperor who banished his own sister, Claudius’s
niece Agrippina the Younger, to a remote island
where she had to catch sponges for a living.
By the way: Agrippina the Younger?
Remember that name.
Anyway, Claudius’s life under Caligula continued
to be a weird mix of awful and kinda OK.
In 38 AD, he married Valeria Messalina, an
influential member of the court, and, in 39
AD, the couple had a daughter: Claudia Octavia.
Yet this wasn’t exactly true love.
Messalina married Claudius because he was
her ticket into the imperial household.
The moment they’d tied the knot she systematically
began committing adultery with everything
with a pulse.
The fact he was being cuckolded on an almost
hourly basis only added to Rome’s general
impression that Claudius was comically useless.
But it was this comical uselessness that made
Caligula treat his uncle more like a pet than
a rival.
And it wouldn’t be long before the poor,
abused dog bit back at its master.
By 41 AD, the knives were out for the mad
emperor.
In this case, literally.
On January 24, Caligula was stabbed to death
outside the Palatine Games.
In the city, his wife and daughter were assassinated
in their home.
But the conspirators had been so focused on
killing Caligula that they hadn’t planned
for what came next.
The result was that Rome slid into near anarchy
that day.
In the senate, emergency debates were even
held on restoring the Republic.
For the Praetorian Guard, this was worrying.
The private guard of the imperial household,
they effectively got all their power from
the system of emperors.
Revert back to a republic, and they were done
for.
What they needed was a new emperor.
Someone who could take Caligula’s place
on the throne.
Ideally a relative.
Ideally someone weak, who could be manipulated.
They found their candidate in the most unlikely
place.
At the moment the bloodshed erupted, Claudius
had been in the imperial palace.
Fearing he might be next, he’d hidden behind
a curtain.
And there he was still cowering when a Praetorian
Guardsman yanked it back, looking for all
the world like he was going to stab the old
man.
But there was no more bloodshed that day.
No murder of Caligula’s uncle.
Instead, Claudius watched in dumbfounded silence
as the Praetorian Guard knelt and hailed him
as their new emperor.
Now, powerful as they were, the Praetorian
Guard couldn’t just unilaterally declare
Claudius emperor.
If the senate had really wanted to restore
the republic, there would’ve been very little
all these guys now kneeling around a curtain
could’ve done about it.
But the senate was too divided.
So when the Praetorian Guard presented their
candidate, there was no united force to stop
them.
The day Claudius was declared emperor, you
could almost hear the city groan.
Really?
This idiot?
But Claudius wasn’t an idiot.
These grumbling Romans didn’t know it yet,
but “doddering” Claudius was going to
become the greatest emperor since Augustus.
Stepping Stones
to Greatness
If you’d been
a Roman citizen in the early days of Claudius’s
rule, you probably would’ve felt like things
were off to a bad start.
One of Claudius’s first acts was to bung
the military a hefty bribe to stop them rebelling
against him.
But that still wasn’t enough, because in
42 AD the governor of Dalmatia decided to
go into rebellion regardless!
This was pretty embarrassing for Claudius,
especially as some senators sided with the
rebel governor, but it wasn’t fatal.
At the last moment, the governor’s troops
rebelled against him and the would-be revolutionary
was forced to commit suicide.
Still, it’s not like Claudius could crack
down on the dissenters or anything.
In this period, the senate was calling the
shots.
They declared that Caligula’s statues should
be torn down, and they mostly were.
They blocked Claudius’s attempts to bring
Caligula’s assassins to justice, allowing
only the head conspirator to be executed.
By the way, if you’re wondering why Claudius
went after the guys who did him a favor by
icing Caligula, it was mostly about precedent.
Everyone had benefited from Caligula dying.
But you couldn’t have people thinking that
assassination was a legit way to remove an
emperor.
I mean, this was Ancient Rome, not Ancient
Ro- oh right.
Well, nevermind.
The other big mistake Claudius made in his
early reign was, oddly, to show mercy.
Remember Agrippina the Younger?
Caligula’s sister, Claudius’s niece, and
Nero’s mother who got exiled to that random
island?
Well, Claudius brought her back to Rome.
Pardoned her.
Set her up with a new husband to look after
both her and Nero.
In the long run, this would prove to be a
fatal move.
By the end of 42 AD Claudius was so insecure
in his position that it was entirely possible
there would be yet another new emperor within
the year.
What Claudius needed was a major victory.
A military conquest that would show the world
he was more than just a doddering old man.
Luckily, he had just the place in mind.
Nearly a century ago, the great Julius Caesar
had failed to conquer a rain-soaked island
north of Gaul.
That island’s name was Britannia.
And Claudius was gonna bring it into the Roman
empire.
There’s a lot we don’t know about Claudius’s
conquest of Britannia in 43 AD.
Our only real source is Cassius Dio, who was
born over 100 years after the invasion.
But we do know that there were two major battles
with the Britons, finally leading to the establishment
of a crossing point on the Thames.
We also know that Claudius personally went
to Britannia just in time to lead his troops
to victory, a move that won him major plaudits
back in Rome.
We know, too, that he wasn’t the only emperor
involved in the war.
The future emperor Vespasian was among the
commanders in Claudius’s army.
On his own initiative he conquered the southwest
of Britain all the way to modern-day Exeter.
By the end of 43 AD, Claudius had done what
even Julius Caesar couldn’t.
He’d pacified the south of this rainy island.
While there would be trouble with the Britons
in the future - Boudicca launched her famous
revolt in 60 AD - for now, Claudius was riding
high.
Back in Rome, Claudius was awarded a triumph.
For the first time, the average Roman in the
street was looking askance at the emperor
and saying “hey, this dude ain’t so bad.”
Well buckle up, ancient Romans, because, for
a while at least, things are gonna keep getting
better.
Changing Attitudes
Today, Claudius’s reign is best remembered
for territorial expansion and for the fact
he wasn’t either Caligula or Nero.
But there were domestic triumphs, too, and
they went beyond merely building aqueducts.
Claudius was the first emperor since Augustus
to really shake up the bureaucracy.
While Tiberius had contented himself with
the odd purge, and Caligula had just done
whatever wacky stuff popped into his mind,
Claudius tried to seriously reform the empire.
One of his key achievements was to introduce
Gauls into the Senate.
Gaul had been under Roman rule for the best
part of a century, but the Senate was still
reserved for those born on the Italian peninsula.
That was all fine and dandy when you were
a small conquering force of Italian groups,
but when you were a vast multinational empire,
it was less than ideal.
Claudius was the one who broke the taboo on
letting non-Italians into the lawmaking process.
Although it caused a massive fight at the
time, it likely saved the empire in the long
run.
Claudius also championed the rights of slaves
and ex-slaves, bringing in a law that made
it illegal to kill your slave for no reason.
To modern ears that might sound like one of
those things that should really go without
saying, but before Claudius there had been
nothing to stop a Roman citizen coming home
from a bad day at the forum and stabbing their
slave to death.
In tandem with this decree, Claudius began
promoting freedmen inside his own court.
He made ex-slaves head of his correspondence,
head of the palace treasury, and placed them
in other positions too numerous to count.
For the senate, this was just another outrage.
These guys were former slaves, the lowest
of the low!
And now here they were, among the emperor’s
closest advisors!
Perhaps its no surprise malicious rumors began
to spread that the freedmen were really the
ones controlling Claudius, and not the other
way around.
Not that Claudius was a perfect ruler, even
if you agreed with all this stuff he was doing.
He was prone to issuing odd decrees, such
as the ruling he passed that farting in public
was good for you.
Emperor Claudius, guys.
History’s first proponent of “better out
than in”.
Overall, though, you’d be hard pressed as
an ancient Roman to say that Claudius was
doing a bad job.
Oh, sure, the senate stank of imperial butt
gas half the time now, but stuff was otherwise
measuarbly better.
Finances were again on a sound footing after
Caligula’s excess.
The judiciary was functioning well, with Claudius
even personally hearing cases and granting
clemency where the law demanded unduly harsh
punishment.
Yet despite all these undoubted improvements,
the Roman elites just could not get over the
fact that Claudius was… well, Claudius.
He still limped.
He still stammered.
His wife still cheated on him.
And, for the toxically macho Romans, that
was simply too much.
In his years in charge, Claudius was forced
to put over 300 people to death for plotting
against him.
Pretty much every week brought some new assassination
plot or planned rebellion.
Yet Claudius dodged them all, wandering obliviously
through the drawn daggers like Buster Keaton
in a hurricane.
But while Claudius was becoming an expert
at avoiding assassination attempts, there
was one he wouldn’t see coming until it
was far too late.
Goodbye, Uncle
In 47 AD, Agrippina the Younger’s wealthy
husband dropped dead in mysterious circumstances,
leaving the emperor’s niece in need of a
new man.
This was fortunate timing, because the emperor
was about to be in the market for a new wife.
OK, so remember Claudius’s wife Messalina,
the one who kept cheating on him?
Well, she was still cheating on him like she
was trying to break some sort of record.
Which she possibly was.
It’s said Messalina and a famous Roman prostitute
had a competition to see who could sleep with
the most men in a single day.
Messalina won.
But Messalina’s plans went further than
just getting her kicks behind Claudius’s
back.
Like everyone else, she was still convinced
the emperor was an idiot, to the extent that
she actually married another man in a lavish
ceremony in the heart of Rome.
The plan was that she would kill Claudius
and her new husband assume the throne.
Instead, word of this incredibly not-secret
secret marriage got back to the emperor, who
was all like “wait, what?
That’s a stupid plan” and had Messalina
killed.
And so it was that Claudius became single
again just as Agrippina was looking for a
new squeeze.
Now, if you’ve already seen our Nero video
- and, yes, we did these emperors out of order.
Just trying to keep you on your toes - you’ll
know Agrippina was a woman desperate to secure
herself against future poverty.
However, the way she went about it was all
sorts of eww.
Throughout 48 AD, Agrippina set her sights
on seducing her uncle Claudius.
Of course, it takes two to tango, and Claudius
was just as creepily open to the suggestion
as Agrippina was.
When they got married on New Year’s Day,
49 AD, the official reason was to unite the
two branches of the imperial family.
But Roman society at large was pretty sure
it was just a convenient excuse for Claudius
to live out his weird incest fantasies.
But not everyone saw the marriage as a PR
disaster.
For the past decade, young Nero had been living
with his mother, the two quietly biding their
time.
Now, that time had come.
In 50 AD, Agrippina convinced Claudius to
officially adopt Nero as his son.
A year later, she pressured the emperor into
naming Nero his heir.
Now, Nero was technically co-heir, alongside
Claudius’s previous son Britannicus.
But that hadn’t stopped Caligula from seizing
power alone.
And it wouldn’t stop Nero either.
The last act came in 53 AD, when Agrippina
made Nero marry Claudius’s daughter, Claudia
Octavia.
From having nothing just a few years beforehand,
Agrippina and Nero had maneuvered their way
into the heart of power.
She was the emperor’s wife.
He was the emperor’s adopted son and heir,
and married to the emperor’s daughter.
It should’ve been blindingly obvious to
anyone watching that Agrippina and the teenage
Nero were preparing for a hostile takeover.
But, as he had been with Messalina, Claudius
was blind to the flaws of his new wife.
Oblivious to the danger he was in, it’s
likely he never even realized what was happening.
Agrippina and Nero made their move on October
13, 54 AD.
That day, Claudius abruptly died from a sudden
sickness.
While it’s not certain what happened, tradition
holds that Agrippina bribed a court taster
to slip Claudius poisonous mushrooms.
Whatever the truth, the moment the emperor
was dead, Agrippina led Nero to the Praetorian
Guard and had him declared sole ruler of Rome.
And that was that.
The reign of Claudius was over, and the time
of Nero was here.
And what a time it would be!
As he grew older, Nero would get crazier and
crazier until he finally…!
But you’ll have to watch our Nero video
for the rest of that story.
As for Claudius, he was deified after his
death, worshipped as a God by his former subjects.
Compared to the fates of Tiberius, Caligula,
and Nero, this was a bit of a win.
Even Nero revoking Claudius’s deification
in the 60s AD didn’t dent the accidental
emperor’s popularity.
A few years later, Vespasian would restore
Claudius to his place in the pantheon.
At the end of all that excitement, then, what
should we make of Claudius?
Well, from one angle, he was still a bit of
a disaster.
Don’t forget: without Claudius marrying
Agrippina, you don’t get Nero, arguably
the worst emperor of all.
But, to look at it from another angle, his
story is one of inspiration.
Here was a man born disabled into a society
that routinely killed its disabled members,
only to rise to the very top.
Once he reached the top, he ruled with a sense
of moderation and sanity not seen since the
days of Augustus.
He made life in the empire fairer.
He saw his subjects not as toys he could break
on a whim, but as actual people.
In the end, Claudius may not have been a truly
great emperor like, say, Trajan.
But he was a good man.
Decent, kind.
Not cruel.
Everything his successor would fail to be.
Perhaps that fact alone is enough to justify
his place in history.